hello um I'm I'm Kristen Wigg um I I
thought of something pretty fun that we
could do I gathered all the wigs that I
have in my closet and I'm gonna throw
them on and create characters from the
wig inspiration um I I think it'll be a
lot of fun what will did you did you
bring did you bring my my Christmas tree
you know that I I can't go pick the
trees I have very sensitive skin you
have to bring the tree to my house on a
truck and I wait for it in my living
room and and then I I decorate it I
decorate the tree with ornaments that I
made when I was in kindergarten so I
hope you bring the tree hey hey big boy
did you see me dance at the Vegas
nightclub you did what do you what do
you say we get out of here and I massage
your toes with honey hi I I'm I'm
Shaniqua I I I shouldn't do that
no I am a sexy librarian I've seen you
over here Tom I always love that you
read books and are smart I I don't read
I I just smell I smell the books huh
like once you leave I'm I'm gonna smell
yours too
look look look what I found oh I'm I'm
Michael Jackson well guys i had a lot of
fun I had a great time and uh maybe I'll
do this again soon bye